this is the reason interview with Nick
gespi all
right all right thank you so much and uh
my guest right now is Coleman Hughes a
27-year-old uh I don't know what you are
you're like you are a uh you're a jazz
player you're a trombonist you're a
podcaster you're an author you are a
cause celeb you're kind of an instigator
uh you you've done it all right I
suppose so I don't think I instigate but
people seem to disagree yeah Wherever
You Are Trouble Follows which is pretty
good um you went to juliard for a while
as well as and then you graduated from
Columbia yep I was at juliard for a few
months and then decided nobody really
learns music in school yeah and no one
really learns anything in music school
so I decided to Pivot and I still play
music to this day but did you learn
anything at
Columbia I don't know you know that I
mean it I mean I guess you learned how
to pull things off of poles and things
like that right and demonstration I
learned how to pull pull down hostage
posters and lost puppy dog posters and
all all the rest you were also uh you
know his podcast is conversations with
Coleman and we're going to talk about
that in a little bit um but uh he's also
got a book coming out in February called
uh the end of race politics argument
Arguments for a colorblind America um
let's start with that what you know
briefly what is the case for a
colorblind America well first of all I'm
very happy to be here I'm uh happy to be
in front of a Libertarian audience years
ago I remember seeing a an article which
said that Libertarians of all political
factions have the highest
IQs I don't know if that's true yeah I
don't think it is it's not true yeah as
somebody who I've spent 30 years hanging
out with Libertarians I don't know well
I was hoping I wouldn't have to dumb
myself down but I
I um yeah please for our sake speak
[Laughter]
slower so what is the what is the case
for color blindness in a
nutshell uh we are human beings and
despite the uh you know despite the
philosophies of people like Michelle
Fuko and others who I know you have some
admiration for there is such a thing as
human nature one of the uglier elements
is is
tribalism um the tendency to form tribes
based around you know any variable
really but ethnicity and race to devalue
the lives of others to
compete and this has played out in
history everything from you know
genocide at the worst end to just
everyday social mistrust um at the low
end in
America unlike most places with which
have defined the concept of a Nation
around an ethnicity whether people will
admit it or not America has tried to do
something different where you can come
to this country be any race color or
Creed and Define yourself as an
American this is a fragile experiment
it's not uh it's not an easy experiment
it's something with without precedent
and one of the one of the challenges
that result is that we all have to
figure out how to live with each other
um and trade with each other and
befriend each other and and so
forth without succumbing to our worst
tribal instincts some of it's inevitable
but the question is how should the state
minimize
this now the answer that arose during
the Civil Rights Movement from people
like Martin Luther King by Rustin going
back to A Philip Randolph was
essentially that the state should not
make any laws that take race into
account one way or the other you should
not try to discriminate against people
really for any reason you should not try
to discriminate to repay people for past
discrimination there should be something
which I borrow from David berstein which
is called the separation of race and
State
and in the long run this is the best way
to govern this fragile experiment so uh
two things one is you know when you say
okay so year zero starts now because you
know it is kind of just a brutal irony
and a paradox of of America as a country
that's founded on a Creed rather than
you know an ethnic Identity or
commonality and it also has the worst
version of slavery where uh from uh my
readings which I think are accurate I'm
not sure but American slavery the really
unique contribution was that the
children of slaves were also slaves like
in most other societies that was not
necessarily the case but you know what
do you do with that you know that is a
brutal horrifying Paradox right that on
the one hand you have people talking
about finally this is a place where all
men are created equal etc etc and by the
way we have instituted the worst form of
kind of race-based uh uh race-based cast
system known to you know known to
history up to that point without getting
bogged down I I would quibble with the
worst form because you know the the Arab
world took some 14 million slaves from
Africa into the Middle East the reason
there's no black people as a
subpopulation is because they died they
were castrated they didn't leave
Offspring Brazil unlike America had to
repopulate itself with more and more
slaves each generation CU they died off
and they didn't bring famili so it's
it's it's a complicated
story I believe that uh in in the
transition from the old world where
slavery was normal everywhere on Earth
there was no such word or concept as
racism really until about a hundred
years ago
because there it wasn't a pathology it
was just the norm in the transition from
the old world to the new world that we
all prefer to live in which is a world
of Human Rights Classical liberalism and
so for individualism I think there's
bound to be a period of
hypocrisy so there there's no other way
to make progress such massive progress
without there being a period of
hypocracy in between and I do not hold
that against the American
project um a lot of people now will say
um you know and we'll get to this in a
second talking about color blindness as
the goal of somebody like Martin Luther
King or a generation of leaders in the
Civil Rights Movement people now reject
the idea that color blindness is even
possible um where you obviously don't
agree with that U maybe you could
explain why and where does that come
from the idea that we will never get to
a place where we are actually dealing
with individual uh each other as
individuals we only ultimately see each
other as markers of some group identity
that overwhelms whatever particularity
we might have in any in any you know
specific
instance well first I would concede that
most of all most of our ideals are
unattainable uh if I were to sit here
and say I want a peaceful Society no one
would mistake that for the belief that
we will actually get to a society with
zero murders per year it's never
happened right we take that as a kind of
north star that guides us when we are
choosing between A and B whether whether
in Life or in public policy I view color
blindness the same way I'm under No
Illusion that Humanity will completely
eradicate the racial tribal instinct or
racism or bigotry itself but I feel that
color blindness it's the north star that
we should use when making decisions
about public policy interpersonal and so
forth as for the second question where
does this idea um come from that it's
it's no longer the
goal uh in the 60s there was a consensus
for a short period of time that color
blindness was the way to go this was the
high era of the high classical Civil
Rights Movement if you if you want to
call it that shortly after that the
country experienced massive
rioting the likes of which was basically
not seen again until like Rodney King
and then
2020 and uh you know in the 70s
something started brewing in the cies
called critical race Theory um the
brainchild of Derek Bell and Kimberly
krenshaw which basically agreed with the
white supremacists on the
fundamental idea that race is always
going to be everything these naive
people that think we can aspire to
something higher than being obsessed
with race are exactly that they're naive
and the only thing you should do in life
is hunker down into the tribe in which
you born and try to get as much power as
possible and um as as Logan Roy from
succession said life is a a fight a
fight for a knife in the mud yeah so
that's what life is except I was really
hoping if you're were going to quote HBO
series you would have gone with sex in
the city but um you know we're not there
yet as a society right I heard this was
a PG show so um you um uh you talk about
um you know so race-based affirmative
action or race-based policies are
definitely out anything that is based on
that kind of a kind of immutable
characteristic I guess um but you do
talk a lot about class-based uh programs
that will help level things out or help
people who don't have opportunities get
opportunities can you sketch out what
what what are those programs uh you know
what do they look like and what
justifies that as opposed to you know
color blindness is out but but class
Consciousness is
it yes
so fundamentally I think
that and I I overuse the word class it's
not really precise
socioeconomics in general um how much
money you make income
wealth this is a much closer proxy for
disadvantage than racial identity is in
other
words if you pick 10 people from the
country at random from Kansas from New
York from and you wanted to rank them by
privilege right which is a little bit of
a you can question the project to begin
with but if we're going to do that
project it's wiser to use their
socioeconomics than to assume that the
black people are at one end the white
people are on the other um to to lump in
a white white guy from from a you
know proverbial trailer park in Arizona
with uh a black kid like me that grew up
in a wealthy suburb of New York whereas
using socioeconomics you're getting
closer imperfect as well but much closer
to what we mean when we say someone is
disadvantaged so then what are the what
are the kind of uh benefits that
somebody would get say if you know I
don't know they're lower middle class or
or their lowincome uh what are what are
the types of programs that you envision
that would be helpful to make Society
better so this is I mean as as a
philosopher I have the luxury of
painting the abstract picture without
filling in all the
details but look there are already there
are there are already um social programs
that are far more you know uh widely
subscribed and popular like earned
income tax credit need-based financial
aid in in
colleges
that not going to argue that they're
perfect but they are they're based on a
scheme that is generally more correctly
identifying the people that have less
Advantage than the regime of race-based
policies that has become normalized over
the past 50 years do you how do you
define yourself kind of ideologically uh
or do you um and you know then what is
kind of what's a theory of government is
government there to help um you know is
is it a night Watchman State um where it
it's just there to maintain kind of
property rights and to uh adjudicate
disputes between people is it there to
make sure that all people participate or
can participate um could you talk a
little bit about that it's a good
question truthfully I found every theory
of government to be insufficient
so I I'm not a subscriber of any
particular Theory um I i' I liked Tyler
Cowan's idea of quote State capacity
libertarianism quite a bit which was
basically the idea that markets are
fantastic they are the source of the
world's wealth
unlike many people would want to
acknowledge but a lot of our problems
today
necessitate um having a a very
functional State that's capable of
occasionally doing big things and doing
them efficiently and helping out I mean
you know somebody who grows up below the
poverty line and may not have both
parents available or anything like we
can we can give them a little to kind of
so that they can participate more fully
in absolutely have a safety net yeah um
let's talk about TED okay the uh
conference you famously and I say it's
famously it's a fascinating story I
suspect that many of you are familiar
with it um it's partly famous because
you've talked a lot about it and you
have uh but um you were asked to give a
talk at Ted about colorblindness um what
happened so I I don't know if you've all
heard of The Strand effect you've heard
of that I think it was uh May begin the
details wrong but I think some someone
took a picture of Barbara str's house or
something it was it's more comp yeah she
she tried to she tried to get the
California Coastal commission not to put
her a picture of her property on a
website that was available to the public
and then by kicking a stink up about it
it went from having been viewed by like
five people to hundreds of thousands of
people so Ted is the barbish drand of
um and I don't mean the singing voice
um so basically uh CH Chris Anderson
invited me to come give a talk along the
lines of what I've just been talking to
you about I gave the talk and uh
immediately on stage I saw a few a few
people that were visibly upset by it
sort of in the room but but largely the
crowd thought it was within the bounds
of acceptable
conversation uh the next day I start
getting some messages saying there's a
group called black at Ted which is upset
by my talk hurt I think is the word that
was used and um I offered to talk to
them and you know they didn't they
didn't want to so on and so
forth uh in a nutshell what happened is
that rather than release my TED talk
normally like they would any other they
asked me
to agree to a series of kind of strange
release strategies where they would tag
a rebuttal to my talk to the end of my
talk in the same video or a debate that
I participated in with someone else
would be combined into the video all of
which I thought was unfair since there
were no factual errors no nothing like
that um So eventually we we agreed that
they would release my thing normally and
then two weeks later I do a debate with
somebody so I did the debate with Jamal
Buie of the New York Times which you can
you guys can all check out and that was
staged by open to debate which I
sometimes guess moderate for and it's a
great debate I mean it's very good open
to debate did a great job as they always
do and um it came out but uh I'd put the
whole thing behind me but then Tim Urban
who's a great blogger also happens to
have given the most view Ted Talk of all
time on YouTube what is it about
procrastination okay Al I knew I would I
keep meaning to watch
[Laughter]
it so he tweeted
uh that he's pretty sure Ted was
intentionally sandbagging not
promoting um
selectively uh not amplifying my video
because every other Ted Talk had you
know minimum 400,000 views maximum
800,000 mine strangely had 70,000 was
the only outlier in the whole
batch uh and so you know I I I at this
point I went public about this because I
had kept up my end of the
bargain um and they
hadn't and it ended up bringing much
more positive attention to my video and
negative attention to Ted uh and there's
also an interlude where you know Adam
Grant this University of Pennsylvania
social psychologist yeah big social
psychologist said that my talk was
inaccurate using a meta analysis that
really made no sense and then he got
upset when uh his name was outed as
having to having tried to sort of deeps
my talk and it was a whole Fiasco which
you know ended up bringing more
attention to the whole thing but details
aside the The crucial thing that
happened is that Ted like many
organizations is caught between a
faction that believes in free speech and
Viewpoint diversity and a faction that
believes if you hurt my feelings with
with even Center left center right or
God forbid right-wing views you need to
be censored um these are the the same
kinds of people who say that speech is
violence who say that they were actually
hurt um or felt unsafe because of my TED
Talk was the language that was used uh
these are the same kinds of people right
now that see Hamas Hamas slaughtering
children in front of their mothers and
say that that's that's not violence
that's resistance right um but a poster
of a hostage on a telephone poll hurts
them yeah or my recycled Martin Luther
King is an attack on their identity
right so this whole this whole language
unfortunately Chris was not he he didn't
he didn't put his foot down with his
staff in the way that he ought to have
and I think he's taken a lot of heat and
Ted has taken a hit from the outside
world as a result um do you do you I
mean it's it's a lot of extra work and
things like that but do you feel like in
the end um it worked to the benefit of
your point of view and your ideas I
think it did you know TR truthfully I I
was engaged in good faith with it the
entire time I was very happy to be
invited to Ted I felt
great with with 90 literally 99% of the
Ted community of all colors came up to
me after the talk and they they thought
it was interesting it's it's really a
situation of a heckler's veto there's a
tiny minority of people that do not
believe such views should be heard and
they have outsize power and it when
people aren't willing to stand up to it
they it can make it seem like they're
everyone yeah you did you experienced
that as a student at Colombia as well I
mean you were active and outspoken
person I mean you really I mean it's
incredibly impressive as an
undergraduate you were already becoming
a public
intellectual um you know but what what
was it like being a Colombia cuz that
was kind of maybe or maybe not wor past
Peak wokeness but you were an
undergraduate there at a moment when
college campuses were really into
shouting people down cancel culture and
things like that totally yeah I remember
I I in college probably my second year
2017 I had a conversation with someone
and we kind of realized that there was
there was this moment in college where
you sort of come out of the closet with
a
friend as not
woke and you just you you you put
yourself out there and you hope to God
that they're also not woke and they're
usually not that's the thing most of the
time almost the the the vast majority of
of kids on these college campuses are
not hookline and sinker woke in the
sense that they believe speech is
violence that they believe um asking
somebody where they're from is racist uh
all of this stuff but there's a radical
let's call it 5% I would really call it
5% maybe 10% but there's a there's a
radical Fringe that is very loud and
very confident why do you think you know
in college campuses it seems like the
administrators are totally oh yeah like
those 5% 5% speak for everybody or it
you know it it just seems like the
adults in the room or in the system have
given up and they're like okay yeah
we're scared too where does that come
from I think you said it I think they're
scared too you know they they have a
they in this culture they have quite a
bit to lose especially the
administrators the the the
administrators have everything to lose
if they get a reputation as a racist the
RW that could if not end their career it
could derange the next five years of
their life to have a single article on
the internet calling you a racist for
any reason doesn't doesn't have to be
good a good reason I know there was I
can't remember which school in
California it was maybe you'll remember
but there was the the example of the
college professor the Mandarin Professor
who was teaching the word naiga naiga
which is like a in Mandarin it's like uh
it's like saying that uh it's like
saying um almost you'll hear if you go
well we're almost in Chinatown but
you'll hear people say it all the time
if you say it quick you know when I walk
through neighborhoods I don't see
race it's all little lit L to
me well anyway he got suspended for
saying a a normal Mandarin word that
sort of sounds like the n-word with a
soft a in
English most most people they they see
things like this happen over and over
again and they think look I I have a
family I have a life I
don't I can't I can't lose all of it
like so and and they're not necessarily
responsive to donors um administrators I
mean um so so they they do a cost
benefit and this is how this is how um a
small group of people can take over a
culture or impose tabos over a whole
culture that some 90% of people disagree
with um you mentioned uh a couple of
times uh Martin Luther King Jr um he's
obviously one of the most uh important
people in your kind of intellectual
firmament what you know what draws you
to Martin Luther King
well he's he's really
uh he's a rare figure for a few
reasons one
is the the depth and breadth of his
knowledge he he has a great essay called
my pilgrimage to non-violence where he
explains in detail what it is that he
learned from Plato what it is that he
learned from Kant from Marx uh why he
rejected
Marxism um how he integrated all of the
uh what Western European Canon into his
line of thought and then also brought
with it uh the the kind of Baptist
preacher element integrated all of it in
a way that was rigorous and inspiring to
uh blacks and whites alike
and not only that successfully
implemented a political program which is
a totally different skill
set um he he gave he gave the country
Goosebumps and and changed the country
as a result
fundamentally uh it it's something very
few people could
accomplish and um are you are you
religious at all or Christian at all no
you cuz that is like a huge part of his
rhetoric right I mean and and you know
the the figure of Jesus uh forgiveness
uh Salvation things like that I mean he
he offered a deliverance from sin
whereas it seems like part of the woke
narrative or woke rhetoric is that we
are all sinners but there's no way to
you know get past
that so I I I'm a secular person I'm an
atheist I can't bring myself to believe
in any any of the man-made books but
it's a big butt I believe that secular
and SEC secular
people want to sanitize the Christian
element of of Martin Luther
King because to admit that his
Christianity was a core part of his
success would cast doubt
on um on the hope that secularism can
can stand on its own two feet what do I
mean by that I mean when Martin Luther
King got up there and said in Christ
there is neither Greek nor Jew black nor
white Bond nor
free that made sense and gave Goosebumps
to the black public to the white public
Etc he was speaking a language that
people understood not just in their
prefrontal cortexes but in in their
hearts there's no secular equivalent to
that statement that really resonates
with people to such an extent and that's
a problem for someone like me who is
trying to update in many ways MLK which
is that I'm not a Christian I can't
speak that language honestly and even if
I could the country isn't Christian
enough to resonate with it now in the
place of Christianity instead of uh
instead of rational Enlightenment
liberalism completely filling the void
it has filled that void but what has
also partly filled the void is woke
social justice ideology and Robin
D'Angelo ISM which as as John mcar and
many others have pointed out is a kind
of
replacement replacement Christianity
instead of original sin it's white
guilt they're different ideas but
they're the same shape in the puzzle of
of the mind and uh you know it's it's a
it's a um a flaw that you can
never uh that you can never get rid of
but you have to make weekly or you know
um um weekly
um uh um visits to whether it be church
or or a Dei session in order to
constantly fight in other words you can
never get rid of it but you have to
fight it your entire life right yeah um
another person that you've mentioned is
Bay Rustin who was one of King's uh you
know kind of bleeding lights uh as a
fascinating figure and I forget when it
was years ago you did a uh video opet
about Bay russing for the New York Times
uh which is tremendous there's also a
Netflix I can't remember now if it's a
documentary or a narrative film naril
about Rustin yeah but who is Beed Rustin
and why does he matter so much byed
rustin's he he's one of my great
intellectual Heroes probably more so
than King even he was
um he was born in
Pennsylvania raised by his grandparents
who he thought were his parents for most
of his
life uh was a communist very briefly and
and then a socialist and civil rights
organizer in the
1940s and uh he was uh you know this is
one of the interesting things like Rosa
Parks is remembered for refusing to give
up her
seat on the refusing to give up her seat
on the front of the bus and go to the
back
many people had done this before Rosa
Parks she was not the first to do this
right by Rustin did this 13 years before
she did and got beaten to a pulp by the
by the by the cops because of it Rosa
Parks was just the one um lucky enough
to make the history book the country was
ready in in other words so he was right
there from the beginning he ends up
getting involved with Martin Luther King
and helping him start his organization
the southern Christian leadership ship
conference though he omitted the word
Christian initially because Rustin was a
Quaker
um he organized and and led the March on
Washington at which Martin Luther King
gave his famous eye of a Dream speech he
read The List of Demands at that
event um and he was a just a beautiful
essayist throughout the entire period
that very few people know about
um an important fact about why he isn't
known more is he was was openly gay and
he was arrested uh he was arrested for
being caught in a car with a
man and in fact Dr King was blackmailed
by Adam Clayton Powell um who there's a
to this day a Boulevard named after in
Harlem was blackmailed by Adam Clayton
Powell who threatened to expose a
fictional gay Affair between Rustin and
King if they didn't cancel a planned
protest on the DNC Rustin is incredible
because he's unapologetically black and
gay at a time when those were really
dangerous he refused to fight in World
War II as country he wouldn't even
register to get conscientious objector
status because he thought the state did
not have that claim on him although
that's not really what I admire about
him and he later rescinded his hardcore
pacifism um what I really admire about
him is that he was more active and more
passionate than anyone you could name in
American history about getting black
people full human rights but he was also
completely clear about the fact that
race is not what's important and when
the Black Power movement came along in
the late 60s and started saying that
actually we don't want equality we want
more we believe black people are not
just equal to white people but better he
was very cleare eyed in saying that this
this is evil this is not just this is
not something for radical chic white
liberals to sort of pay lip service to
this is an evil on the horizon if we
allow allow it to fester and he he drew
that line very clearly in a way um that
that too few people have courage to uh
you know one of the um attributes of
these salons that we're doing here um we
like to talk to people who are trying to
make good faith arguments regardless of
what you're commitments are and things
like that and uh you know with that
announcement I want to uh talk a little
bit about your podcast conversations
with Coleman which is remarkable um in
its you know for its equin
equinity um you have people on that you
agree with you have people on that you
disagree with um you know uh how do you
you know where did that come from
because this um you know this is rare
most people you know when you have a pod
you have somebody on who you completely
agree with or else it becomes a kind of
you know Billow riy kind of shoutfest um
where where does that model come
from I guess I I always like to think as
a consumer I I prefer to hear people
disagreeing in good faith than two
people agreeing in good faith most of
the time it's more interesting it's also
scarcer so when done well a marketing PL
no no actually you know I think it it's
it's it's um it's scarce because it's
it's so rare to get two people in public
conversation when the cameras are on
that are willing to strongly disagree
about something without constant
Interruption and following kind of like
the the the rules of argument if you
will which is I'm going to steal man you
you're going to steal man me I don't do
it enough on my podcast I would like to
do it more but it's act it is actually
difficult to find the right Partners
It's like because a lot of times you you
talk past each other or you're it's
almost like you're not listening to One
yes and all of that's Amplified when the
cameras are on turn the cameras off
often you find someone is a different
totally different person perfectly
capable buddy yeah not you that's true
true um you know uh some of the recent
episodes that you've had on or or
rebroadcast um after the Hamas attacks
in Israel on October 7th one of the
thing uh you know that I I find you
reran an older episode with an Israeli
historian Benny Morris um who is an
interesting figure because among certain
Israelis they hate him because they
think he's too critical of Israel among
non- Israelis some people think he's an
apologist for them can you talk a little
bit about his message and why he you
know he he's like a really interesting
person to be talking to to or with at
this point in time absolutely Benny
Morris is um a rigorous and beautiful
historian of the Israel Palestine
conflict in particular the war in 1948
and the leadup to
it he more than anyone is responsible
for
unearthing what we would Now call
Israel's war crimes against Palestinians
in the 1948
War for this
he was
blacklisted um or at the at the very
least uh denounced by the majority of
the Israeli
uh Academy at the
time uh and by the way I I I kind of put
war crimes and scare quotes here because
not to trivialize them but because the
concept of a war crime was not really a
thing in 1948 the Geneva Convention to
which we refer now didn't happen till
um so he he Unearthed with brutal
honesty what Israel did in the 1948 War
Visa
expelling you know some
70 possibly a little bit more 70,000 or
so Palestinians uh from their
homes but as he has gone on he has not
seen
that admission as synonymous with saying
that Israel
is in the wrong he has a very bracing
honesty about the fact that the
Alternatives facing Israel at the time
were
expulsion of its a fifth
column or genocide against its own
people that's that's those are the
Alternatives that that were being
faced at the time and he the reason he's
hated or criticized at the very least by
both sides he's hated by some on the
Israeli side because he he he will he's
exposed some of those things that many
Israelis have not wanted to
admit but he defends them as the only
realistic option that Israel
had right and that's why he is called
the worst possible names by people
sympathetic to to Pal the Palestinians
because at the end of the day and I
think he's right about this Israel has
always wanted peace more than
Palestinians
have they they atrocities to be found on
both sides but there's not an
equivalence to be found on both sides in
terms of wanting a practical solution
wanting a peaceful solution so he has
been very clear that Israel is on one
side of that while at the same time
being very honest about the uglier parts
of the history I think the figure that
is usually uh given for displac pales
say 700,000 right not 70,000 700 are
700,000 are displaced 70,000 were
expelled I see okay thank you yeah so
this is the the myth on the Palestinian
side has been that they were all
expelled that's not true the the the old
myth on the Israeli side was that none
were expelled and Benny Morris has done
the most careful research that roughly
on10th of those that were displaced were
expelled um you also and I want to I
just I want to add context to this
because I think it's
important millions and millions of
people were displaced and expelled by
wars in the
1940s um millions of Germans were
expelled from Poland after World War II
when Poland took a chunk of
land the the of those Millions the only
people that maintain that they still
have a right to return to the places
where their parents or grandparents
lived in the 1940s the only people are
Palestinians so I think it's it's it's
very crucial to understand the context
of what war was in the 1940s before we
had our modern concept of war crimes and
the Alternatives that people actually
faced at the time um you know I found
that episode particularly you know
really informative and and challenging
and just kind of mind-blowing uh you
also did a two-part episode with a Brit
named Andrew gold about anti-Semitism
and whatnot which is fascinating I
highly recommend people check that out
and then you you know and this this is
part of what makes the the podcast great
is that you asked your audience like who
is a good person who's the best person I
should talk to who would present a pro-
Palestinian point of view in the current
situation and you talked with a guy
named yusaf uh man um how do you think
that episode went and um you know again
how how did how did did your audience
respond well to that because it was it
was uh charged uh kind of dialogue but I
also found that incredibly um you know
kind of mesmerizing and
enlightening it's hard for me to know
what the reaction is I get comments that
say things like you know Yousef didn't
acknowledge any of your
points um I get comments that say things
like Yousef was right about everything
and you're ignorant about
history um and I don't know how to
balance these two at the end of the day
I I get I but I get many comments that
are just glad to have heard a debate
where um both sides at least got a
decent amount of air time a debate that
felt a little bit better than cable news
I would like to that that is the soft
bigotry of low expectation true it
really is it really is uh I'd like to do
better I'd like to do more of those in
the future and I'd like to challenge
myself
to um you know hand handle it better as
well because it's um it's a difficult
it's a difficult skill I feel maybe it's
been atrophied by
underuse in our society where we are
less and less talking to people that
disagree with us but Yousef is he he's
someone that he doesn't even believe in
a two-state solution he believes in a
one-state
solution uh with a right of return again
this is something that no no one would
take seriously for any other group of
refugees from a war in the 1940s right
of return for every Palestinian whose
parent or grandparent lived somewhere on
Israeli territory in
1948 which would create a demographic
majority of Palestinians in
Israel um and in my view would lead to
an instant attack on the Jews of Israel
a a bloody Civil War that would be
horrible for for both
sides uh but he feels that and I don't
think I'm strongman him that if that
were to happen What would result would
be a a happy Society where people hold
hands and there's no violence and
everyone has
rights and I think that this is
profoundly naive um I think it's
profoundly naive and that that was the
Crux of our disagreement you know he
didn't really want to talk about October
7th right I tried I tried to get him to
talk about October 7th and and and the
war he didn't really want to talk about
it every time I brought it up he would
go back to the history which is fine but
I also feel it betrayed a bit of of
embarrassment because how do you defend
how do you defend the dismembering of
children in front of their families the
burning of entire families this is not
this is not the behavior of Freedom
Fighters This is the
behavior of
of Barbarian jihadis bent on genocide so
I think it was a bit telling he didn't
want to go there are there you know
either from race relations in the United
States or elsewhere are there models for
you know the intensity of the Israeli
Palestinian situation particularly now
but really for the past 60 or 70 years
are there um examples of good
resolutions to this kind of uh you know
seething conflict I don't know that
there are any good resolutions but there
are livable
ones the partitioning of India and
Pakistan was absolutely bloody and
brutal the atrocities committed on both
sides were uh in in the partition were
akin to what Hamas did on October
7th
um but that was a two-state
solution that was a two-state solution
and my point my point to youf is that
the only realistic solution is a
two-state solution but
unfortunately Palestinian public
opinion
um has not been able to let go of of the
dream of from the river to the sea that
all of Palestine will be there so um
this is this is the core of the dispute
in my view uh hopefully you know that
may not be true I uh there was uh in
foreign affairs uh uh a piece that was
written by people who run What's called
the Arab barometer which had just it's
an ongoing set of surveys and public
opinion polls of uh people in various
Arab countries and they had just
completed a survey of people in Gaza and
there a majority of people actually were
you know said they were in favor of a
two-state solution and only about 20%
said they believed in a one-state
solution that meant getting rid of
Israel so we don't know and of course
that's you know that's a thousand years
ago now post yeah I mean I've seen a
million polls it's it's hard to pick any
one of them as as representative I think
all right well um I for one I'm a huge
uh admirer of what you're doing so thank
you Coleman Hughes for talking of
[Applause]
[Music]
reason